[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
randall chamblee on loan from the golf
channel
i was watching last night live from the
masters brando of course was on there
rich lerner
and uh you guys were you you were
dissecting bryce into shambo
on the driving range i mean that looked
violent there
did it did it look violent to you uh and
what do you expect out of him this week
you know his club head speed the other
night was 154 miles an hour
to put that in perspective dustin
johnson is 119 miles an hour
i mean the difference there i mean it
would be the difference between
i don't i don't know dustin johnson and
and somebody
who just picked up the game or something
i mean you know even if he just swung
what what he's been averaging all year
was 133rd the difference between dustin
johnson
uh and him is 15 miles an hour that's
the difference between dustin johnson
and jim furyk or brendan todd
so what do i expect i don't know if he
takes that 150 mile an hour clubhead
speed out on the golf course he's going
to be
chipping to he said he could drive
number one
right he's gonna be chipping to five
he's gonna
he will literally be chipping to all
these play if he if he has any semblance
of accuracy with that it'll be
it'll be unlike anything we've ever seen
before in the game
but he's also talking about this secret
weapon in his bag that nobody knows
about
yeah well i think he's pretty good at uh
at work in his brand
he's really good at that you know i mean
he's he's good at
teasing us and peaking our interest it
has to be a driver i don't know what
else it could be
um well he did mention cobra
quite a few times when he was talking
about good at that yeah
yeah yeah he's good at product placement
he's really really good at that listen
but if someone was going to give me a
free bentley
i i you know i'd probably work it i'd
probably work it in too i'd go you know
this is you know i'd say it's not the
cadillac swings it's the bentley swing
i'd figure out a way to get it in
i would uh is this a good thing
is this what golfers now are going to
try to emulate
yes i think it's the tip of the iceberg
because you know when tiger woods came
along
nobody could do you can't replicate
tiger woods you just couldn't you can't
you can't have his imagination you can't
have his speed
uh you can't have his accuracy and you
can't have his mind
but what bryson is doing there's there's
a an absolute road map for this
and in college kids and young amateurs
they're paying attention and they know
this road map they they they can see it
in
all of these um information gathering
devices
they could see it on force plates and
and so they know how to move
like bryson's movement because you know
we we saw bryson he was swinging
117 miles an hour a few years ago now
he's 154 miles an hour and he's told
everybody how he's done it
so the road map is is there and we're
going to see more and more of this
and is it good i don't know everybody
leans in when he's hitting the driver
and they watch and the ratings go up
when he plays
well it feels like he's he's the new
star like jordan's piece back justin
thomas is always interesting rory's
interesting
uh dustin can be great but you know
doesn't move the meter
uh john rom like people who don't know
golf it feels like no it's like when you
wait for barry bonds to come to the
plate
you get to watch the shambo come to the
plate
18 times you know during a round
that's very much what what it's like i
mean those analogies have been drawn
you know i mean distance is always uh
you know alluring everybody leans in
john daly came along and it was
you know 1991 nobody forgets what
happened there but you know john daly
didn't let's just say quite have the
discipline of bryson
schambo right and bryson deshambo is is
is also working into this golf swing
accuracy elements and he keeps trying to
get better and better and better
so you know golf has never really quite
seen anything like bryson he's
much longer in proportion to his fellow
peers than john daly was
longer than nicholas was longer than
tiger well
he and tiger when tiger first came out
with a combination of accuracy
it's it's kind of similar to what tiger
was doing in 97.
um but i remember when tiger first uh
happened on the scene and he was very
successful and i was talking to fred
couples i said
can that swing hold up he said no
it can't eventually you slow down your
body just can't take the torque
whatever weight you put like how long
does deshambo
have what's his window of opportunity
here
the thing with tiger is that we don't
know if some of those injuries came from
the gym but
i i suspect a lot of those injuries came
from him restricting with his lower body
tiger hardly turned his hips and created
that massive coil
but if you do that you put so much
pressure on your back so it really was
an accident or an injury injury rate
waiting to happen
bryson isn't doing that he's swinging
the way fred cup
not fred couples he's swinging the way
uh bubba watson or
phil mickelson have swung where he fully
turns his hips
okay so that's less interest on the body
it puts less stress on the body so
i hear people say that it looks
interesting i don't see it that way i
think he could go on
obviously his swing will slow down as he
gets older but that's not for
he's in his 20s he's got another 10 15
years of this but it looks
so violent i think his back is going to
go right through his sternum i think
i mean right yes but you know look jamie
salowski is is a player he's copied kyle
berkshire is a player he's copied these
are long drive guys
um i i paid quite a bit of attention to
kyle and
jamie i've never seen jamie get injured
i've never seen kyle get injured
you know i just don't see those guys
getting injured because they don't
restrict
and they and they they fully release and
and by the way bryson is paying
because bryson you've heard him talk
about wanting to live to be 120 or 30.
you've heard him say these things
like he you know he he he's not he's not
planning on getting injured and hanging
it up anytime soon i mean this guy
has got but brandon you know who he
described
he reminds me of uh elon musk
like he's i almost made it last night i
went sylvester stallone writing rocky
last night but
elon musk you know and he reminds me of
elon musk in a lot of ways
um one elon musk after he made all the
money on paypal
bet it all on spacex and tesla bet at
all i mean took this
huge risk everybody thought he was crazy
and it paid off
bryson bet it all on this golf swing
because he was making
millions of dollars and having a nice
career but he bet it all on this he
could have
shuffled off into oblivion and then when
bryson talks you can't quite understand
what he's
talking about you have to go do google
searches and that's the same when elon
musk talks
so they're innovators they're creators i
saw a quote
from zuckerberg uh the other day and it
said something like
the only real risk in the world today is
is not innovating
i mean that is the strategy to fail
because
there's so much information and so much
access to information if you're not
ready to change and take risks
and that is a recipe for failure and
that's that's bryson dechambeau that's
elon musk
is dechambeau liked on tour
i i think i think so i mean there's
probably a few that are you know
probably roll their eyes when he starts
talking but i
you know when you i've never seen like
if anybody gets paired with tiger or
phil
you watch them they walk down the
fairway if there's two or three guys
they're playing golf with phil
or tiger when when they're walking down
the fairway the other guys are turned
looking at them okay there's no question
who the big cat is
in that group the tiger and phil when
they get paired with bryson
and bryson's walking down the fairway
they're turned looking at him
they're talking to him they're asking
him questions
because he's the guy who's done all the
research nobody's done the research the
way bryson has not not from a player's
perspective
uh any information on tiger uh
no probably nothing other than what
you've heard i've been
following a doctor uh an orthopedic who
who puts these
great um posts on twitter
these great threads about what tiger is
likely to be going
through but uh but i guess
as he said is no news is good news if
there was anything going on that was bad
we would have heard about it and uh so
the whole golf world held his breath
that day and we're all crossing our
fingers that uh
that he heals up beautifully and uh and
makes a comeback yeah
yet again another comeback would be uh
tremendous before i say goodbye
uh with all the nice things you were
saying about uh bryce and shambo
who's your pick i'm gonna pick justin
thomas
uh you know i'm gonna there's
differences between those guys
i think justin has you know a little bit
more creativity in his game
and he works the ball left to right you
know over the last two or three years
he's been the person who's hit more
greens than anybody else at augusta
national
so and that's that's that matters more i
mean
you always hear about how putting is so
important at augusta
of course it's important everywhere but
it's it's about
fourth on the list at augusta first
things first are strokes being td green
and nobody's better than
justin thomas in that regard at augusta
national that's my pick
randall great to talk to you we'll be uh
watching live for the masters uh
coming up later on today thank you thank
you dan always nice talking to you
cheers
that's uh brandel shambly golf channel
analyst you can catch live from the
masters on golf channel for extensive
daily coverage today
and through the final round there